وزير الدوله القطريه للشؤون الخارجيه
سلطان بن سعد المريخي عن قلقي بلاده من
الاثار الانسانيه للحرب في اوكرانيا على
المدنيين وقال المريخي في كلمه له امام
مجلس الامن الدولي ان بلاده تجدد الدعوه
لاطراف الازمه الى التحلي باقصى درجات ضبط
النفس لايقاف الحرب والوصول لسلام مستدامه
ان دوله خطر التي تحرص على تسويه الخلافات
والمنازعات في كل مكان بسبل السلميه
تاسف لاستمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا التي
تجاوزت 18 شهرا منذ اندلاعها
ومما يقلقنا بشكل خاص الاثار الانسانيه
لهذه الحرب على المدنيين العزل كما ان
تداعيات هذه الحرب على الاوضاع الامنيه
والانسانيه والصحيه والاقتصاديه على الامن
على العالم ازدادت تعقيدا وتفاقما خاصه
فيما يتعلق بجهود الامن الغذائي العالمي
ومكافحه الجوع لا سيما على الدول الناميه
والفقيره لذلك تجدد دوله قطر دعوتها
لاطراف الازمه الى التحلي باقصى درجات ضبط
النفس لايقاف الحرب والوصول الى سلام
مستدام
وشدد وزير الدوله القطري للشؤون الخارجيه
على استعداد قطر لدعم اي جهود او مساء
لوقف الحرب في اوكرانيا
دوله قطر تدعم مبدا سياده واستقلال
اوكرانيا ووحده اراضيها في اطار حدودها
المعترف بها دوليا والالتزام الكامل
بمبادئ الميثاق وفقا لمادته الثانيه التي
توجب على الدول الاعضاء تسويه المنازعات
الدوليه بالوسائل السلميه
والامتناع عن استخدام القوه او التهديد
باستخدامها في العلاقات الدوليه كما نحث
كل الاطراف الى الالتزام بتعهداتها كامله
وفقا لمبادئ وبنود القانون الانساني
الدولي والقانون الدولي لحقوق الانسان
السيد الرئيس ختاما تجدد دوله قطر
استعدادها لدعم اي جهود او مساعي تهدف الى
ايقاف الحرف في اوكرانيا والاشاده بالجهود
القيمه التي تبذلها الامم المتحده
والمنظمات الانسانيه للاستجابه العاجله
للاحتياجات الانسانيه الطارئه المدنيين
بالاضافه الى جهود مواجهه تد الحرب